yeah hi so i'm joyce from geek culture
singapore's nice to meet you all today
nice to meet you i've watched the first
friday episodes and coming from someone
who wasn't very familiar with the show
before i really loved it
so uh how familiar were you guys with
the show prior to filming and what drew
you to this project neither one of my
parents are american and so it wasn't
really one of those kind of novelties
growing up in my house um
but of course i watched the original and
i watched the movie to prepare for this
one um
i think what drew me to it was
on a couple different levels i mean
starting with i read the audition scene
and the fact that it was
the different layers of like reading
moby dick on a glacier in the middle of
a lost planet in space i was hooked
um but also this idea of being
in a big family that goes through this
adventure that was something that was
really attractive to me uh as an only
child and
all of the kind of complex sci-fi and
special effects that went into it i
thought that was super cool i'm just a
public school kid from chicago
um who grew up in the circus so but
loving sci-fi
um i grew up loving star trek and robots
um me and my best friend we would go to
a robot store called robot city and we
would build and play with the robots the
new robots that they got there
um
so getting to like
be
will robinson and have
a robot was kind of surreal
and the family and how they managed to
stick together and how they weren't a
perfect family
but
they
they had their flaws
but they managed to
stay a family and they managed to
succeed
and they used each other's differences
to
really make it through this
adventure
he said it all yeah i think he just did
it uh how was it like filming in canada
did you have any interesting moments on
set
i had forgotten having not lived there
in 20 years that
it's rel there's relentless rain so it
was you know we were there for seven
months it was a long time
and i the the show
is really sort of cinematic in scope
it's a big
adventure big kind of dirt under your
fingernails adventure and so we did
shoot a bunch of it on a studio with a
green screen but a lot we shot on
location um
which
you know is sort of hard work but makes
the show sort of
beautiful to look at
what is your favorite part about each of
your characters
um
what i like about will robinson
is how
he um
is how he grows up in this series and i
think that will inspire a lot of um kids
who
don't feel comfortable in their skin who
don't feel comfortable in who they are
um i feel like that can inspire a lot of
kids to
maybe see these people who don't feel
comfortable as themselves who may seem
different to reach out just like will
robinson did with the robot
and to look past
how people look look past how people
behave
because
there's always a reason
why people
uh
my people are the way they are just like
the robot people
um or the people who created him or
whatever his past was
that made him who he was when will
robinson met him but when will robinson
looked past
who the robot appeared to be he saw
another life form
that
was
going through something very similar
that will robinson was at that time they
were both confused they were both scared
so when will robinson
becomes friends with the robot
and he grows up and becomes more
courageous and becomes more
fearless
i think that that will
i hope that inspires a lot of
uh
adults and children and that's what i
like about will robinson
taylor what about you
i think judy doesn't hesitate to do the
right thing
and
that's something to aspire to be
very admirable um
yeah i love i love her for that reason
and how well do you relate to character
tony um well i think john robinson
i think what i've what i like about him
is that he acknowledges he he realizes
he has the humility to realize that he
has
many failings as a parent and a husband
and he
through the course of the series
tries to make amends
and and
you know tries to
forge a better relationship with his
kids and uh his wife one that he's
neglected in the past and i i think that
kind of i i really admire him for that
it's great uh well larson's face isn't
lost in space without the iconic robot
so i wanted to play a little quiz game
with you guys yes so us at geek counter
we're all about our geeky sci-fi roblox
and so i have 10 pictures of
classic famous pop culture robots okay
so uh i'll be showing them to you you
can raise your hand and first one to
raise your hand and get it right we'll
get a point and i have a special prize
for the love oh oh okay
ready
i already know
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Laughter]
one point
oh
it's right there give us a clue
uh his name has a number in it yeah nine
four
eleven five four three two one oh you
could get a point for the movie as well
oh
yeah no we haven't yeah yeah i'm really
kidding myself what is what is it yeah
pass his name is johnny five from short
circuit oh short slightly
raise your hand
so one for molly
wally
[Laughter]
old one oh my god that's from the black
hole yes
but i can't remember the name of the
robot
huh
[Laughter]
his name is vincent vincent
but it's a bit hard to catch up to him
now because we only have one left who's
keeping score because i'm doing better
than i thought i would
i just know what i have
no yes and last one i think we all know
it's the fastest hand
oh see through um
oh come on
i am surprised
yeah
and i
gosh thank you you're welcome what do
you have to say as the official king of
pop culture robots
i just want to thank
i want to thank the academy
um
for bestowing me with the knowledge
um no i
don't thank you thank you so much i love
this i'm gonna put it on my shelf and
admire it every day
thank you so much
thank you so much
[Music]